[Music]
Condoleezza Rice served on President
George Herbert Walker Bush 'iz National
Security Council
she was his senior director of Soviet
and East European affairs and special
assistant to the president for national
security affairs later on rice was
Secretary of State and national security
adviser under his son president george w
bush she's with us now for an interview
you'll only see you'll see first on CBS
this morning Secretary Rice good morning
one of the measures of leadership is
that leaders make the people who work
for them better how did George - what
did you learn from George Herbert well I
learned from President Bush how to be a
good public servant and what that meant
I learned to care about relationships
before you need it to call it somebody I
remember as a young staffer I got this
note early in February said I want to
congratulate Helmut Kohl on his victory
in the Bundestag and I was the
specialist I thought what victory an
accompanist on but he was reaching out
before he had to ask Helmut Kohl to do
something difficult for German
unification and that's who he was he
absolutely valued relationships and and
valued people and I I think I learned a
lot from him about that I don't love so
much about how he loved his family I saw
an interview that he did with Jena his
granddaughter where he said I used to
fear death but I don't anymore because I
think that afterlife is going to be
pretty good but he really loved being
with his family can you tell his family
story Krystal there were people of great
faith and he was a man of great faith
and so I'm sure he was actually looking
forward to seeing mrs. barbara again
started Robin who he grieved for
throughout his life but I remember being
up at Kennebunkport for a church service
with the blen we were sitting outside
and and the priest was a little bit kind
of new age as somebody who was visiting
and he said now I mean nobody it does
anybody out they have a perfect family
and it was of course meant ironically
and George hatred if you put raised his
head and said I do of course he knew
that they were not a perfect family but
it was to me a statement of his
unconditional love for his children for
his entire family and I think one of the
reasons that I bonded with them was
because I had that sense of family
he came to California and after he I had
left government he met my father it was
one of the great moments for my dad and
so family it's just so important to the
bushes and I love that President Bush
and his national security adviser Brent
Scowcroft credited you with helping them
write their book about the end of the
Cold War how did you help President Bush
reflect on that era only one term
president but one of the most
significant periods in American history
well just to help remind them how really
significant it was because in fact these
are people who it was never about them
when that's famous story of after the
Berlin Wall fell all of us rushing to
the Oval Office and saying mr. president
you have to go to Berlin for Truman and
for Kennedy and for Reagan and he said
what would I do dance on the wall and
then he said something else he said this
is a German moment not an American
moment and I note that notice that
Angela Merkel the German Chancellor is
here he really was in so many ways the
father of German unification because he
had to bolster Helmut Kohl he had to
bring Margaret Thatcher and meet Iran
along who were somewhat nervous about
the unification of Germany but it was
never about him and I think that's what
made him such a great president at a
time when the Soviet Union had to be
quietly put to rest to be triumphalist
at that moment would have been very
dangerous it would never have occurred
to him to be triumphalist that was self
equality and what would make him cranky
I'm Kerry how many wonderful stories
about him well humility was his best
quality
I also remember telling him that
Gorbachev do you remember mr. president
the Gorbachev made his last call to you
before the Soviet Union went out of
existence he made it to you and he
thought nothing remarkable about that
so that's he was what made him cranky
being late or anybody else it was late
and he shares that with his son did you
ever play speed golf or the meet you
I did play speed golf with him up at
Cape Arundel golf course and I mean guys
it means that you you barely hit your
shot before you're moving on to the next
one and you really don't let anybody
else hit their shot before they're
you're moving on I can remember putting
with him you know reading a putt what
was that you just kind of put it and
moved on he never wasted a moment even
on the golf course right it's almost
like polo out of a golf cart but you do
actually get out of the cart
returning back to his presidency though
you talk about humility what would he
say now about I mean obviously he's
being eulogized and remembered but I
wouldn't he also want people to know
about the reality of some of the
decisions you make and the toughness of
it and it's not all roses and perfect
decisions I think that's such an
important point because as we look back
we see a road that worked out so well
Germany unified Eastern Europe was
liberated the Soviet Union had a
peaceful death that was thousands of
little decisions along the way some of
them incredibly consequential some of
them very tough do you tell the Germans
you know you really do have to stay in
NATO as unified Germany can you find a
way to deal with the Soviet Union that
is collapsing in a way that's with
dignity but without giving up on the
principles that the United States had
held a since the end of World War Two
and these decisions in retrospect look
easy in fact they were hard and they
were tough but George HW Bush was always
out ahead of us in some ways because he
had principles that let him we didn't
spend much time thinking should we unify
Germany because he had great faith in a
democratic Germany that had for more
than 45 years been a good ally of the
United States and so that is the the
lesson of this that great public
servants do their jobs in some ways so
well that they achieve the goals and
when we look back we don't even realize
how hard it was it's been fun to look
back at his life Connie and I think if
you live to 94 for the most part healthy
and at the end you die with the people
that love you love and love you
including your dog that's a really
beautiful way to go I think absolutely
it is
and I think that this was a life of his
was life of consequence that's quite
clear in his presidency you know even
domestically the Americans with
Disabilities Act how many Americans
today can go to a football game or to a
restaurant because of that a life of
consequence but also a life surrounded
by family and friends one of the things
that I admire about the bushes in
general but him in particular friends
from decades and decades and decades ago
when your friends stay with you no
matter how famous or how much how much
difficulty you get into you know that
you've lived a great life your race has
been run as as the Bible would say
you've run your race well yeah there's a
story about the caretaker who took care
of the place at Kennebunkport who was
invited today and was very heartened to
be included it's it's it's amazing and
you know there will be people there
Kennebunkport there will be there people
there from from Texas and there will be
world leaders there Thank You secretary
Conte